each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
a pleasure to welcome to menses from
West Virginia University to Microsoft
tim is actually the co-founder of a
promise conference and his off of many
papers in value of empirical soft
engineering and machine running and
today he's going to talk about the
future of empirical soft engineering
okay thanks Tom thanks the invitation to
come here thanks for Microsoft you
getting me out here thank you all for
attending our people online watching
this they can call in with questions
email Oh afterwards okay now my email is
not here was it on the broadcast so if
it's not Tim at menzies us I'll be glad
to take your questions this is a
prototype talk we're building up to a
far as Shalom myself for doing this tour
kaduk see in hawaii in may there'll be
90 minute briefing so apart from
anything I talked about here technically
if you have general comments about where
to take the talk or what might make more
interesting to a broader audience that
would be useful so this is my debugging
run amongst a friendly audience so your
comments are welcome this talks by
myself for a shelf on the fraunhofer
institute we also have contributions
from the University of Auckland John
Hoskins and his stuff will be in the
middle when we talk about the visual
wikis so just a little bit about our
surf web first and I the creators of it
there's four very prominent open source
repository so soft oh sorry I shouldn't
open source there's four large
repositories the software engineering
data everyone uses there's the sirs repo
from Nebraska there's course all the
open-source repositories for ashole had
a thing called sea bass funded by the
NSF from 2001-2005 who's heard of sea
bass okay it no longer exists it
literally no longer exists the license
fees for the proprietary database is
used for it are not paid because there's
no funding any for so all that data is
gone away the promised data set we put
it up with WordPress on Andre
host and i think i paid twenty bucks a
year to keep it going and the idea there
is that if you publish it if you publish
a paper at the promised conference we
ask you to offer the data that supports
the conference the supports that
publication and as you can see down at
the bottom here there's you know we have
a 100 and 130 data sets and what the
what the conference does is it fuels the
repository there's a very exciting group
now based on all that work what's next
that's our question what's next so we
want to do more and more and more and
more data mining not just on different
projects but again and again and again
on the same project so the proposal here
is not just to learn from a project but
to learn and relearn and relearn and by
data mining I don't just mean building
predictors I mean automated agents will
implement prediction monitoring
diagnosis planning all the things we
want to do for adaptive business
intelligence just to comment about
adaptive business intelligence you may
also refer to this as predictive
analytics a complaint against the
software engineering research world is
that the most prominent most widely
cited working as useful for engineering
is typically to do with software testing
it's always as if the software
engineering research community has
mostly given up on influencing the early
part of the software process cycle we've
gone for the end stage where we're not
going to hurt the developers too much
we're going to say you write any crap
you like and we'll test it back to
conformance for you I want to work at
the unpopular end of the software
lifecycle I want to work at the
beginning processes where managers want
to make decisions about budgets about
resources that have vast impacts I don't
want to work at the micro level of
fixing the if statement I want to find
out if we have enough people to build
the whole software now by adaptive
business intelligence I'm talking about
learning and relearning and relearning
will be a thing will come back to many
times and things like how to detect a
death mark project not just how to
detect something but how to repair that
death march project how to find by cell
points for software artifacts how to
invest more or less in staff training or
development programs how to prioritize
software inspections how to estimate how
much is going to cost
how to change things so that the cost
the number of bugs you deliver the time
it takes to live a change these are the
sort of things I want to do with my
adaptive business intelligence tool kits
for software engineering now this talk
is a plea for industrial partners to
join us it's also a roadmap for about a
decade more of research if you leave
this talk with you know I wasn't sure
about blah blah blah it's because I'm
not sure about blah blah blah I'm trying
to paint a picture of what I'll be doing
for the next ten years and if I don't
have all the answers yet well watch this
space now there will be some new results
at the end that I think are quite
interesting but hopefully I'm going to
raise more questions and answers by this
talk that's its point that's its goal I
want to talk about data mining and
software engineering I want to talk
about all the incredible things that
were now pretty routine the researchers
do all the time was data mining and
software engineering I'm going to put up
six categories and by no means this is
the this is the spectrum this is
incomplete list so if you're not on this
list I apologize but here are some here
some there are people that take software
process data you know how good your
developers are you working on stable
platforms and they do things like
generate effort estimates berry beams
been doing this for about 30 years I've
been doing it about a decade martin
shepard about 15 years and many other
people besides other things you can do
with software engineering the social the
social stuff social metrics for example
work at Microsoft studied which tested
you respect the most and that was a
predictor for what bugs get fixed and so
learning from the social dimensions of
our projects then there's people that
take static code data static code
descriptors of modules and output
predictors for where you're going to
find bugs and many people have done this
work I've done some work here as well as
numerous other people Tom I stranded
Elaine Walker at AT&T and many others
besides other work is trace information
you're watching a program running and
you're learning what and you're learning
what methods call what and things you
can do here is work out sequence of
errors that typically to a bug or if
you've got two modules you don't know
anything about you watch them running
and you work out the API between them
and this is people like tau G and Andre
Zeller and many
others besides then there's the usage
data what's everyone else using that's
working you're doing a tab completion
you've typed half the name of the method
you hit tab and a list of completions
pop up and hopefully that list of
completions is things generally work in
your environment so people people like
Martin remillard with the recommender
systems study the current systems
defined useful parts to explore next
then you've got all the text mining
people that will accept any textual
format all the way Andy Marcus views the
Eclipse and the code base is a text
mining problem and he does fault
localization you give him the the text
of the bug report and here comes back to
you with a prioritized list of 20 to 30
methods to look at saying this may be
where the bug will be he's pretty good
at it and the text mining stuff is
getting fascinating we can do things
like learn the currently the actual
software process followed by an
organization not some you know CMM dream
of what you think the process is but
what actually goes on now the state of
the art of all this is firstly a lot of
this is research in very little hits
industry if data is collected at
industry it's usually forgotten that's
the sad truth very rarely kept and if it
is kept usually it's usually are right
once read never another level of stuff
and this is and as I go down this slide
you going to fewer and fewer people and
you're generally stepping away from
industry practice into more and more
rarified research there's a lot of
dashboard work visualizations for
feature extraction but the intelligence
is left to the user so there's many many
software packages that will help you
connect to large corporate databases and
produce impressive screens of
multi-dimensional data like this but
often in these dashboard based approach
the final intelligence step is left to
you the fact that you're going to
combine features from here and learn a
threshold that gives you a rule for
action is typically left to you the last
final step of aggregating the features
and say this is our local policy is not
supported by dashboard technology in
some ways it's like all the stuff we're
seeing now support for massive parallel
execution very exciting work certainly
needed for the upper level intelligence
like we certainly need
port for you know distributed file
systems all the stuff you get with
Hadoop but even after you got had a poor
ganoub parallels or MapReduce working
you still have to put the intelligence
on top it's like having I shouldn't say
bus in a software organization maybe I
should say you built the taxis but not
the taxi drivers okay so I want to build
the taxi driver that knows how to
navigate through now it's important that
you build the taxi the roads are on or
less all the things the dashboard
technology gives you all the things that
the parallel data miners give you but
even after that there's still work to do
there's a lot of work on data mining
just have a lot of work done by
Microsoft for example all the people in
this half of the room in fact
surprisingly I'd quite I didn't know
there's what happened but now now now
what I'm not seeing is the real learning
I'm seeing out of learning predictors
but i'm not seeing monitoring of old
theories and doing revisions now just a
little aside for the geeks here the
instance-based learning people would
smirk at this point because they've got
a constant review policy they can just
pour into their library but if it is
ever a business process of a reflecting
over the available data and writing down
a policy and saying here this is the way
we do things in this organization even
the instance based people do not have a
real own device for the policy extracted
from their instance space although see
recent publications by Menzies and Brady
now of course at some point someone says
data mining stupid data mining gets it
wrong and I say hey no one's perfect
look at all the mistakes people make
goodness me data miners are pretty
stupid people do you know how dumb they
are have you read the wikipedia page on
list of human cognitive biases 38 ways
we get decisions wrong 30 ways we make
mistakes with probability 18 ways social
pressures it cause detrimental social
decisions 10 ways at our short-term
memory problems stop us making good
decisions at least with data mining we
can repeat the analysis separately and
ordered the conclusion which is not to
run down people some of our best friends
or people I'm even married to one what I
want to talk about is creating agents of
community
tease each with novel insights and with
limitations and if we work together
maybe we can shine light on the darkness
of each other's soul or something maybe
together we can find more things and if
you work separately that is all this
change what we call empirical software
engineering research well I think it
does there's a lot of interest in
science to point o Ben Schneiderman's
call to arms the growth of the World
Wide Web continues to reorder whole
disciplines it's time for researchers in
science tech new take advantage take
collaborations in the next phase and
reap the potential intellectual and
societal benefits of having hundreds of
thousands of people reviewing data
generated what would that look like well
it's not going to be like this it's not
it's I don't think that once we've got
face-to-face to sorry Facebook YouTube
and blogging going that we've got these
things going the units that I pass
around between my collaborators around
the world are not hey this is the movie
I went to its units of scientific theory
its data I need more tools then Facebook
YouTube or blogging but it's certainly
true that these tools mean most people
are online a lot of the time and these
tools mean that underneath them or the
network layer of the internet is
available to a lot of people how does
that change the nature of the scientific
work well I think it adds roller skates
to software engineering I think you know
what I want to do is use data mining all
the time on software engineering data if
you're interested this guy achieved 80
miles an hour going through here that's
not his speed record his speed records
300 miles now being dragged behind a car
on a flat horizontal space now but this
was more challenging of course because
of the g-forces going around the loop
there just an aside now what's the
difference with what I'm saying in
standard software engineering research
well I would characterize standard
software engineering engineering
research 1 point 0 as follows it's lots
of case studies where you gaze at an
organization and see what you doing
majan Margaret Mead going into Samoa and
sometimes their experiments where we
actually change local conditions and
often those experiments have to be on
very restrictive case studies often the
student project with this you know 40 40
people in a university
class we make half them use Java and
half thing you see we can't with some
conclusion and because the rate of data
extraction is small and because the
amount of data collected is very small
often very simple statistical analysis
methods which date prior to World War
two are used on these things now if you
go from here the science to point 0 then
all these people the case study and
experiment we will become data generator
people they generate the data and then a
large number of data miners replied to
that data so a small group of people
generating data a much larger group of
algorithm to analyzing it later if you
doubt that there's 10,000 possible data
miners I refer you to a recent
publication of mine in December
automated software engineering we're
really seventeen thousand different ways
to configure instance based reasoning an
instance based reasoning is just one way
of doing these things so there's a huge
space of analysis methods it's not like
everything's just a t-test there is a
vast space of analysis methods that is
mostly unexplored happily if we do crowd
sourcing we have not tens of thousands
but hundreds of thousands of people
eager to do the analysis every research
PhD doing software engineering faculty
members like me given the ready ready
availability of data mining tool kits
business users from around the world
trying to find what is the most
important pattern for their data so this
is the crowdsourcing picture of
empirical software engineering version 2
point 0 now this I think Souls a problem
with case with case study based software
research now in the case study based
research I think it's very powerful for
defining problems and highlighting open
issues and has and has generated a large
number of candidate ways we might
improve a project um if you look at on
Albert andre's indeed run box 2003 book
you have in this book hundreds of ways
which some people have found in some
projects improve those projects you know
reduces defects delivers early and you
see landmark publications based from the
case study based people who offer
piercingly clear statements of problems
which researchers might not have gotten
to without a clear insight
example kitchens toc 2007 paper asked a
question so simple I I went oh why
haven't I ask that myself before cross
company versus within company estimation
if your organization one and you're
learning something you got access to
data from organization to is it is it
more useful to use your own data than
someone else's data very simple question
and it never occurred to me before
someone posed a very clear statement of
it and this is spawned a whole
subculture of researchers checking to
see if what works here also works there
now the case study based research has
limitations primarily it's too slow to
keep up with technology imagine one case
study / PhD three to five years by the
time that PhD has finished their case
study written it up documented published
that the world has changed there are
still people doing case studies on pair
programming there are still people
studying where the C++ is better than C
meanwhile we're talking you know a
functional programming with F sharp
cloud computing the case study work
cannot keep up with the pace of
technology change the case study work
has produced too many candidate methods
and very little guidance on what messes
to apply to particular projects if you
chose to do all 107 recommendations of
this book your senior management would
tap you on the shoulder and say can you
just give us the three that are most
important and you go oh but this book
offers no guidance on how to pick
between these if you pick up the I
Triple E 1012 standard on verification
and validation you'll see I'll get the
number wrong 87 things you could do to
do the envy on software and you won't
see guidelines on whether on which is
most important for a particular project
you'll also freight about the generality
we know that when people have studied
conclusions from one project and taken
them to another they've found very
little generality that Tom who else was
on your FSC 2009 paper nachi
nachi Oh Tom Zimmerman and other people
& M nochi and others from Microsoft they
took pairs of systems they had 662 pairs
and checked if what learns here worked
there in only four percent of those
cases did what worked there worked here
and if you read the making software book
chapter one forest and me go through the
literature and come up with lists of the
very small number of examples of it
worked there and it worked here and
you'll also read in that chapter a vast
list of and by the way usually it
doesn't work here if it works there so
we need to do something to patch case
study based software engineering we want
a partnership data mining is pretty
stupid it's got no business knowledge we
need those business goals from the case
study based research case study research
is too slow and if you want to check for
generality of those case studies
conclusions that's even slower so how
about we do case study research on one
project to raise questions and possible
answers and we do data mining on many
many many projects to check those
answers that I think is the future of
software engineering now when we do of
this we're talking about learning and
we're learning from other people's data
and so we're talking about ways to
handle large amounts of data that you
didn't collect so I want to talk now
about adaptive agents for handling that
kind of thing why do I want to talk
about adaptive agents for doing data
mining and software engineering well
there's that well this slides a bit
dogmatic the first point the first
slides is around in general rules and
software engineering and quotes
Zimmerman now now it turns out that
there are about five or six general
results and my name's on two of them so
I'm the guy saying that there aren't
many general results at the caveat that
we have found a few ways to port things
for projects to projects but there's not
many what I think is more likely is
there are general methods to find the
local best rules instead of talking
about some overarching theory like a
Kokomo will see mm across all software
engineering perhaps we need to talk
about ways to find quickly the best
local rules if you're talking about
local learning the questions are how
quickly
can we learn the local methods how much
data do we need how to check when the
local methods start failing like
locality might be a function of the
people on the project the current task
any number of factors market forces we
need to know with our theory which we
had still holds and how to repair local
not models so I want to talk about
adaptive agents that watch a stream of
data learning and relearning as
appropriate this I've got time this talk
at 40 minutes at home which means for in
an hour session we should be added 20 to
15 minutes thinking for questions at the
end so which means you could either
interrupt and ask questions along the
way or wait for the end it's your call
there's only there's only is a very
small dedicated audience here so feel
free to interrupt but NF if you've got
questions and you want to hold them off
to the end that's another strategy you
might want to apply as well so what
would a stream of data look like well
supposing you're the chief information
officer and you're receiving data all
the time from the projects and you're
building models that predict the things
and there's some quality predictor
defects if it's something and you're
watching the data coming in and you're
what and you're tracking how good your
quality predictor is over time well
initially initially you don't know
what's going on and as data arising you
learn something and life gets better
after a while you your predictor starts
working for the local project you've got
enough data to make predictions about
the local project and then it will call
that mode one at some point there's a
breakdown where something changes the
developers change the product changes
something changes at which point you
learn again and after a while you get
good and you got another mode and then
after a while there's breakdown then you
learn again and then you get another
mode okay so that's a picture that's cuz
the mental model I've got here learning
and relearning all the time question
don't understand what the y-axis
represents me
at those points where you're saying
there's a breakdown why is that telling
you that you should relearn rather than
telling you that your models saying
something's wrong with the process of
processing what if your model is
predicting good and bad results in some
time oh you know so if you can't so so
if you can't predict anything about the
project right you've lost you guys I'm
sorry the question was how do I know
that this is actually is model break
down a lot of fact that actually
equality produces just drops okay and my
answer was that I hopefully my model is
just a sunny day report guy but you can
look at you know subsystems and say that
was going to take six months and that
was going to take nine months and as
when she when you lose the ability to
make accurate predictions about good and
bad behavior in the project that's when
I go crazy down here and maybe what I
should have done is the y-axis be the
variance of the predictions or although
all the bias of the predictions what
might have been a better measurement
okay now what's different here now this
is not just let's throw Data Miner to
build a predictor most of my research
pride about three years ago was just
this first cliff struggling to get
enough data to learn a mode I didn't
think about what happens when the theory
breaks down it's adding monitoring and
repair tools to recognize and handle the
breakdown of old predictions it's about
being able to turn to business managers
and say you can trust our stuff because
when we deliver these tools to you they
come with meta analysis tools that can
tell you when they're stopped working
okay now if you're doing crowd sourcing
and you've accessed a lot of data for a
lot of companies you can imagine this
process goes on for many companies here
learning modes one through nine let's
imagine these graphs are on top of each
other but the first one is 2009 data and
company two is 2010 data and now you've
recognized you're here in 2011 wouldn't
it be great to work out that mo date
looks very much like mode 5 and mode 2
wouldn't it be great at this point here
to say you know something I've entered
the mode which has been seen at other
companies at which point you could
import prior data and lever the
experience base of prior projects a full
learns from their own mistakes a wise
person learns other people's so that's
the picture I want to offer you and
there's any number of research questions
to sensors this raises anonymization how
do you share data without revealing
confidential information how do you take
a data set preserve it statistical
properties without revealing individuals
in that space that's a massive research
area right now techniques like k
anonymization and many more besides
talks about how do you scale up volume
of data if you're working with raw
project artifacts not some pretty
summary but the you know all the emails
ever sent during the online discussions
on the design and if you're
crowdsourcing take all that data source
of x thousand how do you explain what's
going on to business users if I'm
interested in business users setting
policy and and telling the business
users went to revise those policies I
have to somehow take complicated
theories and show them and it's a center
way to users so I can't show them some
Markov chain function I can't show them
you know the print the linear
combination representing principal
components seven because I'll start
blacking out at that point I sorry a
typo noise from bad data this is nothing
to do with dad's here but if I'm taking
data from multiple different sources and
I didn't control the collection of that
data I'm going to assume that has got
noise anonymization yep there's an
implicit assumption there that if you if
the research community comes up with a
decent anonymization scheme that there
are companies that that wouldn't have
made available dehradun available if it
was not a nice but would it is not
amazing but that what is there and sent
him there for companies or for whoever
that doesn't currently make their data
available that now they're going to so
i'm not sure the microphone picked it up
so i'll see if i can repeat your
question if we solve the onam ization
problem would that solve that a sharing
problem why would companies want to
share well let's say you're the first
company in Arizona to do agile develop
goodness me you might want to learn
experience by the people you know so the
the Linux experiment was a surprising
success we can get large groups to
organize my hypothesis is that some will
end up in a peer in 10 years from now
when we realize we can learn more
together than elsewhere now and any
other part of the world that might
disagree but in the hippie Pacific
Northwest we all share hands and and and
go to Burning Man and dance together
naked and the line I know I go on with
that metaphor but some you're right
there are corporate policies to prevent
sharing let's see what happens in 20
years time same problem that science
your point O has as well which is that
there's there's really very little
incentive for scientists to share their
data set I mean given that we reward
publication and not providing data far
better for me to keep my data set and
milk it for as many publications and
withhold it from my competing so the
question was is there even any precedent
in any scientific field of data sharing
it's 2 replies astronomy has rules about
data sharing if you collect data from
the sky you get it for six months you
get a period when it's yours and then
you have to get get at the hell out to
the community visits from the skies the
promise experiment when we started in
2006 we said no one of a Lionel breann
god bless him said no one will give you
data no one wants to give you data and
it turns out to be insanely easy to
collect data just ask for it we have a
hundred and thirty data sets in problems
we had 50 new datasets last year I spent
two hours with ACN portal last year and
I found 77 papers using the data sets in
promise so I can
to at least two research communities one
of them a software engineering that
doesn't live up to the pessimism implied
by that question will it mean that all
scientific disciplines will share data
again going to bird it burning man and
damp no of course not but some may
papers from which the datasets came
Wilson's that use yeah yeah yeah if you
if you if you if you look for Casey one
in ACM portal it's it's it's it's all
over the place Asmodeus NASA 93 was a
data set that someone gave me at JPL in
2003 and and I can't tell how many
journal articles i get to review that
have Coke 81 and NASA 93 of them and
they're all from promise okay
okay okay for moving on thank you for
those questions now what I want to say
is that the tasks i want to do can be
done by data mining and why is that
important the sort of things i want to
do prediction monitoring planning
classification etc i did it in the 90s
as part of my PhD and i did it in a
logical framework um any formal methods
geeks here abduction belief revision
okay so i was i was an AI illogical guy
in the 90s and i had a thing called well
let's not even talk about it but it
didn't scale my precise reasoning with
logical primitives didn't scale the data
mining stuff scales so i want to cast
all this business intelligence stuff in
terms of probabilistic data mining a
little scale ok now I'm this so so how
would I start well this might change
after visiting Microsoft but after my
recent visit to Swinburne in Melbourne i
discovered the visual wiki technology
that's been put out by the university of
auckland and this is being used around
the world the CDC in Atlanta is using
this for example and in this model
everything you've got in the project is
thrown into a wiki perhaps not shared
with the world perhaps kept without an
internet and in their model you know you
can input text or you can input directed
graphs or you can derive this sort of
semantic graph from the sort of text but
rich associations between things and
their technology you know you can see an
impressive array of different textual
forms here controlled entry for some of
the wiki entries there's even a metal
wiki device they've got for configuring
their wikis some of these wikis actually
have semantics down here is the
enrollment process for a first year
student at the university of auckland
this is an executable model in a wiki
now once you start giving me business
models as part of the visual wiki you
know i can start doing simulation and
learning on that space a very rich
source of data and so what i want to do
is one more slide they've even got a
wiki Vicki builders for configuring
because there's this technology so you
can build a structured working
environment for your people and the idea
is that we just give away this stuff and
you can download this stuff from all
and we asked companies to put everything
they've got into these things we also
engineer a joint key we give all the
artifacts your unique ID an engineer a
joint key to some quality measure that
you care about defects effort something
and then this is the space we learn from
we learn from the naturally occurring
product artifacts now you might say
that's going to be insanely large space
I'll just give you a small hint that may
not be you know the text mining problem
where you have like 100 documents or
written in English and there might be a
hundred thousand words in English so if
you think about the matrix of documents
by Texas it's a hundred lines long and a
hundred thousand columns wide and there
are really really really simple ways of
doing dimensionality reduction really
simple ways this is just one result from
some NASA defect data these were defect
logs for five different NASA systems and
we applied the standard tf-idf thing to
it and all we need to know about tf-idf
is at the linear time feature extractor
that's all you need to know and of all
the words and those defect logs a very
small number of them here here here here
and here scored exponentially higher
than the rest so to turn this text
mining problem to a standard standard
data mining problem we just build data
sets out of the top 100 tf-idf words and
then we had a standard data mining set
with only 100 columns and then I think
ripper and j48 was just fine with this
stuff so there's a lot of interesting
stuff with text mining and we're quite
happy now to work with unstructured data
well this has all been a little bit hand
wavy let's go under the hood is there
any actually technology we can apply
here well it's all data mining if you
think about the what some of the
business problems here here's this
learning curve between you don't know
what's going on and you know what's
going on how do you make that as steep
as possible there's a lot of exciting
active learning technologies for
learning how to find the next best
examples to classify active learning for
those who don't know consider you've got
the world's greatest obstetrician and
you brought her to the hospital and you
give the obstetrician a baby healthy
baby and the obstetrician says that's a
healthy baby you do that all day and you
realize you've wasted the time because
you've only been giving that
obstetrician healthy babies the same
label it would be better to reflect over
the space of babies given to the
obstetrician and the space of babies you
could give that obstetrician and pick
the most informative examples and give
to how to recognize break down how do I
know that this is actually hear the
start of a breakdown or not just a mere
blip and we've got some exciting
bayesian anomaly detection technology
that we want to talk to you about how to
classify mode well that's actually the
easiest problem just I like Bay's I'll
people like other things any number of
classifiers that can work out what's
happening inside a stable mode how to
make predictions well once you're in a
stable mode you've got the frequency
counts of that mode so you can hit do a
lot of what if queries inside that space
now diagnosis and planning a lot of
there's been a lot of stuff in logical
AI about diagnosis and planning let me
tell you diagnosis and planning from a
data mining perspective let's say you're
in this mode 3 where your predictions
for what's going on and generally worse
than two other modes and yes I
understand that the sex act like this is
badly named but just go with the
qualitative nature of it mode 3 our
predictions aren't as good as mode to a
moment slower Plateau so if you in mode
3 and you don't like what's going on you
want to know what happened we were in
this happy place now in the sad place so
what is the Delta between mode 2 in mode
3 the Delta between the two now if
you're in mode 3 once you've worked out
you like what's going on you say what
can I do to make things better and
you've got these two other happier modes
mode 1 mode too so what's the Delta
between mode 3 and these happy places
now if I've said that right by now
you're thinking wait a minute this is
exactly the same process diagnosis and
planning in diagnosis it's a delta
between a happy place and a sad place
and planning is there's a sad place and
happier places there's also provided in
planning you only care about the deltas
that you can operationalize so it's the
Delta times the cost of making that
Delta and both of these I think can be
done with the thing called contrast set
learning and fight and they're also
explanation if you're in this mode and
experts say business use to say we want
to write down policies we want to add a
textbook we want to put something
lor we want to know what to tell our
contractors on how to do there but their
practice what what can you extract from
this and you cannot give people you know
the linear combination of a PCA you know
this they just go crazy so let's talk
about bits and pieces if you ask me dr.
Menzies how much of this is working i
say well bits and pieces of it it's all
it's all this is the preamble to an NSF
submission so you know don't ask for
this working on your desk i can give you
bits and pieces and one thing i can give
you right now is the contrast set
learner and i said the contrast set
learner was the thing that did diagnosis
and planning now the way we got into
contrast set learning was we had
decision trees with weighted leaves a
decision tree starts at one node and
descends descends and each node makes a
decision and drive your left or right
and the decisions take you down branches
and some ranches take you to happy
leaves and some ranches take you to sad
leaves and the plan the the Tarzan Sri
query language Tarzan swinging through
the trees look for decisions that
favored happy branches and avoided sad
branches and when we tried this tree
query language we took a simulator see
4.5 we did our 10 way cross validation
and we had thousands and thousands of
nodes in the trees we couldn't even show
them to the business user it was like
holding up a picture of quantum dust the
tower one returned these tiny tiny rules
incredibly small rules so for example in
one decision tree we had 4593 and 27
branches to happiness moderate sadness
and total sadness white is happy grey is
moderately sad and black is you want to
avoid 4593 27 branches if we imposed
these constraints and this is kokomo
speak so analyst experience and schedule
pressure with just those decisions these
things in these small ranges notice a
lot of the branches have now gone all
those brains have gone all these and all
the sad branches have gone and over here
I've now got here I've got twice as many
equal number of happy branches as gray
branches down here I've got twice as
many happy branches as sad branches and
that requires these constraints down
here now this satisfied the one
powerpoint rule my NASA civil servants
god bless them were busy people I had to
somehow come up with a representation of
a complex space put up on a base on a
slide say these are your options this is
what you can do notice this is 1 2 3 4 5
what if scenarios and here is many many
more ways to happiness and greatest and
sadness but it requires constraining
program or experience which you may not
be able to do so they cross that one out
straight away and down here well here we
don't have to do anything with people we
just have to change the specification a
little bit in the process and that gets
rid of all the blackness so they might
favor this one and then you say well I
want to get twice as many happiness as
grayness you have to change something
about analyst expiry this this supports
the what-if queries now these are tiny
summaries are very very very large trees
and how is that even possible well it
took a long time to work this out but
here's what here's the story it's so
simple few of a decision tree the higher
the decision the more branches you edit
a decision high in the behind the tree
wipes out more things on that side and
the higher you go into decision tree the
narrower the tree so the smaller number
of variables should talk to so it just
naturally found very very small now la
this leads to a very succinct
explanation module if you ask me how to
build a feature detector or graphical
objects where you've got text horizontal
lines graphics vertical lines and
pictures or you've got Boston Housing
very low very high high low very low
resale value standard learners will
produce these structures and even these
which are pretty small in decision tree
land are intimidatingly large for a
business user the defining moment of my
life was I put a tree smaller than this
on a business users table and they'd
spent twenty thousand dollars to produce
that piece of paper and they threw it
off the table I was very proud of that
piece of paper I said what are you doing
they said well this only tells me what
is it doesn't tell me what to change
okay so I went away and built the tree
query language and then other things
happened after that and for Boston
Housing there's twenty one percent of
very low resale houses and twenty-nine
percent of very high resale about houses
but this single constraint changes the
distribution to ninety-seven percent
very high resale number of rooms in the
house and the parent teacher ratio of
the local school and with that
information you can grossly and simplify
your search for high sale high resale
about houses and busting and please
notice you aren't asking the business
users to interpret this stuff you're
doing a very very small thing here now
last year the NASA people were kind
enough to allow 08 2009 Karen Gandhi
bullet was very kind enough to let my
grad students go across to NASA and we
tried this as a shoot-'em-up that we
said what's your state-of-the-art
optimize a numerical optimizer and they
had very complicated simulation models
of flight guidance and control and
please join me in doing a reentry
exercising to the planet Earth you're
going too fast and so you do a quick
dive into the earth to bleed off speed
skip out again the nappage you can make
decisions then you come down and you
land hopefully where the where the
ground crew is and if you can imagine if
you're doing you know at 19,000 miles an
hour small decisions have an enormous
impact on where you land you want to get
here so what are the decisions and this
is hundreds of variables inside these
simulators that drive you to happy land
away from sad land and the tower three
treatment learner that by the way is no
longer a post processor decision trees
it it does other things that are much
more interesting now ran 40 times faster
than their state-of-the-art you know
these are the numerical methods people
at NASA Ames we've got massive super
computer technology and out of ice round
40 times faster and found better
conclusions and that's something to do
with the non continuous nature of their
of their arm flight simulators and
better yet when we produced output we
produced tiny tiny rules the business
users could comment of this incredibly
complicated decision space we produced
tiny tiny rules now it turns out this
contrast set Lerner takes us to anomaly
detection the sawtooth was a fun anomaly
detector and has a problem this is andre
rago 2005 and and sawtooth read data in
eras of 100 instances each
each each instance was had the same
class seen it seen it seen it seen it it
then computed the probability of the
next instance being of that class seen
it and here you see the the average
likelihood have seen it as you go
through 15 eras this is 1500 samples
from 55 claims in an initial
commissioning period all the planes did
the same thing they all take off they
all bank left it all bank right then
they go on five different missions and
the likelihood increases at this point
because they're going all of them a just
flying patrol over coastal all of them
are just flowing through cloud so their
frequency counts increase and then ear
of 14 we do something bad to all planes
we turn off an engine and we kill the
pilot and in all cases this figure drops
two orders of magnitude this is not a
slight tap on the shoulder this is a
whack over the head saying something's
wrong and we didn't have to tell this
device what to look for it just watched
the likelihoods now the complaint
against sawtooth one is that it's single
attribute is based on a bike Bayes
classifier so it treats every attribute
is independent sawtooth two is a post
processor to tie three ty three produces
these tiny rules these things that are
most important to changing behavior so
don't do frequency counts on attribute
Rangers do frequency counts on how often
these rules occur and you'll get a
better anomaly detector we think now
this is very recent this isn't even dry
yet but we read a mathematical analysis
of instance and feature selection and
the statement was that they're the same
in a hyper dimensional space a cell in a
table of data feature and instant
selection is just pushing in the walls
and it doesn't care which way they come
from so we took a long cup of coffee
stared at the wall so what does that
mean okay tar three finds important
ranges that change classes and does it
very fast causes or stochastic Bayesian
tricks almost linear time actually I
shouldn't say that tar for does it in
linear time tar three top floor doesn't
theoretically in linear time tar three
theoretically is polynomial but in
practice it's it's very low water
polynomial now what about any instance
it doesn't have these important Rangers
just call them throw them away what we
realize what tar 3 does is it's a
heuristic way of finding the hyperplane
between classifications so if he is data
before we apply the pruning of throwing
away the rows that don't have the
interesting read here's the data
afterwards you see the test instance
there and other greens disappear there's
a green dot here and here there's a huge
range here if there's small errors in
that test instance and the error thrives
it this way the green is going to just
going to stay green whereas here if
you're doing nearest neighbor small
movements will make a blue green blue
green blue green now noise has an
incredible effect on one nearest
neighbor hears all these different data
sets and we're increasing the noise and
data set precision recall you can see
just drop like a stone as we increase
noise in notice what happens to the data
sets when we input noise but we're only
reasoning about this reduced space of
just the innocent matter it's very hard
for noise to change the classification
this dot can move a long way without
changing from green to blue so this
instance removal method that's a linear
time post processor to a very path past
rule learner gives us noise control and
this also takes us to active learning
this is the diagram I showed you before
here's class one hears class two instead
of class too here's half way the most
informative examples are the unlabeled
examples near these halfway points and
we're doing some exciting experiments
with that and then statistical data
bases preserving the statistical
properties when anonymized data set for
a nearest neighbor algorithm means
preserving the spatial relationships
instance space if this is an instance of
someone you don't want to put out there
is a you space in their region cold by
what I'm talking about here where you
can create a fake a huge space where you
can create a fake
okay so that's that's the end so we're
after industrial partners that will wear
well unless Microsoft has a better
alternative where we can offer people
some sort of repository for their
artifacts in any form at all we're happy
do to text mining over large complicated
spaces now and we need a join of those
products as I'm to some which is key and
then we need to interview their managers
a little bit to get some domain
engineering and all this could happen
behind firewalls we're no longer saying
give us your data and we'll do the
analysis what we're saying now is we
will give you the analyst as an
algorithm and drop it into your site and
that analysts will come with a red flag
saying I don't know what's going on now
I give you some more data to change my
mind and in return will give you
automatic adaptive business intelligence
devices the tunes itself to your local
domain ok so if I've done this right
you'll have now questions I have no
answers to because I've done this right
there's any number of research questions
to be offered here but over T so
questions the comments from the audience
and for those folks watching on video
Tim at menzies us for email comments
over to you Christian ok so like halfway
injured hockey fan out there there are a
lot of cases coming down but because
that's what I'm in case in other
generalizes so the solution is to go
data binding how do you need data mining
just like case studies at scale how do
you let's say you have some some
interesting result you seen a pay
mackay study say okay I want to see if
this generalizes to a bunch of things
it's like there's a lot of difficult
steps because what'swhat's immeasurable
in some context you may not be measuring
and other not about this sir well yeah
but the case studies you seen the paper
that if you pick up scholz guides and
purple software engineering and you read
Steve Easterbrook and and and Margaret
stories most excellent chapter on how to
do on how to do case based software
empirical research and it's really good
stuff it really defines perfectly what
I'm calling case based studies stop
software engineering it's really
excellent chapter I'm not knocking it
but the amount of time required so so so
if you if you take if you wait for the
case study based research it's the Royal
Collection it's the massaging it's this
and that this and that and years later
you get a table of three or four dr dot
points okay if instead you insert a hook
into an active software process you
start mining visual studio with no
intermediate you will get a lot of noise
you'll get a large volume of data okay
but some I disagree that there's you
know not data in unified formats
national government regulations
regarding healthcare records I'm amazed
to find out that the guy three doors
down from West Virginia is running a
medical health records system which he
built to give to remote clinics in West
Virginia with a unified data schema and
this particular data collection device
is now in use in 22 states in America
and six Polynesian islands this is the
guy down the road from me in west by god
virginia you know what are you doing to
see what what unified data sets you can
access
so I'm disagree with right I'm just
doing the premise your questions
I think now she had a question so mine
was born after the back so eventually as
researchers at some point in time some
of this will get published some way
shape or form maybe you know stuff and I
can't actually attach it some sometimes
you normalize results so it's okay for
the data to be behind the firewall the
analysis can actually be anything you
can find out anything that actually says
okay this component is going to have any
person failures when you publish you
cannot correctly publish better software
system just want to have any person
figure no but what you but but but but
you might be able to necessarily is
published a method and say look I can't
tell you the conclusion from this
company I've done that you in fact you
might have even reviewed 1 or 2 30 i'm
not sure but I've done that when i said
look look on open source data sets this
is my methods as a results now the next
section i will mark with informal
verification I'm client informed because
you can't repeat the verification but
this is what happened when i did this
inside a company my ability to predict
the errors came within sixty seven
percent I won't tell you how many areas
i found out 12 name of the company now
that paper needs to have and you guys
have actually done this I've been really
happy was not just a you're unhappy but
I've been very happy with the Microsoft
publications that put out results on
like on Microsoft data and open source
stuff as well right because you can say
here's a technique and behind closed
firewalls we can't tell what's going on
but if you want to check if our
technique works here
so I i don't think the barriers that you
folks are suggesting I've got enough
examples to say that they're not fatal
barriers to all research okay and I'm
and I'm and these examples didn't exist
10 years ago so extrapolating from zero
to two data points we can go out we can
go ahead to infinity pretty quickly
okay the promise conference as it is it
ECM in September it's due dates April 10
I'm PC chair for promise 2011 we're very
excited at case at a third case studies
I shouldn't we're very excited and
industrial contributions if folks want
to produce papers that define a data set
and challenge problems and they want to
do some crowdsourcing a large group
you're working on their stuff I would
strong of course I always encourage the
standard research papers but I would
also strongly encourage industrial
practitioners such as yourself for
putting together challenge problems and
writing for 25 page papers describing
the challenge problems current baseline
results you're not happy with and the
data says they came from so April 17 i
think is the deadline for that i look
forward to all your papers